نبدا صباحنا اليوم بالحديث عن منهم اعز
الناس الى قلوبنا صحتهم صحتنا وسعادتهم
سعادتنا باختصار اذا سالك والدك او اجدادك
عن كيفيه نشر صوره على الانستقرام او
ارسال معايده الى احد الاصدقاء عبر فيسبوك
لا تتذمر من ذلك الطلب بل بالعكس
كن واشرح لهم كل ما يرغبون معرفته في عالم
الانترنت وسلب السبب ببساطه صحتهم العقليه
هذه الدراسه نشرت في مجله الجمعيه
الامريكيه لطب الشيخوخه تقول استخدام
الانترنت له اثر ايجابي على الصحه النفسيه
والفكريه للمسنين اشارت ايضا اعاده هذه
الدراسه الى ان كبار السن الذين
الانترنت بانتظام كانوا اقل عرضه للاصابه
بالخرف من الاشخاص الذين لم يستخدموه بشكل
منتظم وجد الباحثون هذا الرابط بعد مرور
حواليه ثمان سنوات من تتبع حالات لاكثر من
ثمانيه عشر الف بالغ تتراوح اعمارهم ما
بين الخمسين والخمسه والستين عاما لم
يكونوا مصابين بالخرف عندما بدات الدراسه
فجاء استخدامنا الانترنت كمساعد على تطوير
الاحتياطي المعرفي للشخص والحفاظ عليه
والذي يمكن
ان بدوره عن شيخوخه الدماغ طبعا المزيد
حول فوائد استخدام الانترنت والصحه
النفسيه على كبار السن راح يكون مع زميلنا
بعد قليل لميس ابراهيم بس قبل ذلك
ذكرني يا عادل هذا الموضوع كله بيذكرني
باغنيه للفنان احمد مكي اسمها يوم ميلادك
هو بيغنيها عن طريق الراف فيها جمله كتير
كتير كانت تستوقفني وتاثر فيا بتقول لما
تلاقيني قدمت ومش مواكب عقلي جيلك ما
تتركنيش لجهلي وعلمني من غير ما اجيلك
خليك عينيا ونور لي طريقي المنتهى وافتكر
اني علمتك معنى الحياه
كتير جميله كتير خلينا نشوف لميس شو رح
تحكي لنا
من تدريب كبار السن على اجهزه الكمبيوتر
واستخدام مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
المختلفه بحسب الدراسات الحديثه فالانترنت
يمكن ان يربطهم بشكل ايجابي بالاخرين
ويساعدهم على تعلم معلومات او مهارات
جديده من خلال منصات وتطبيقات اجتماعيه
جديده ويمكن ان يؤدي استخدام كبار السن
لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا الى توثيق
ارتباطهم بالاخرين وتقليل عصلتهم فاظهرت
الدراسات ان كبار السن الذين يعانون من
الوحده كانوا اكثر عرضه للاصابه بالخرف
بثلاث مرات من اولئك الذين قالوا انهم
شعروا بارتباط اجتماعي مع الاخرين
وتوصل الباحثون الى ان الذين استخدموا
الانترنت بشكل متكلم مره واحده في اليوم
او اكثر كانت لديهم مستويات اقل بكثير من
اعراض الاكتئاب وابلغوا عن جوده حياه اعلى
مقارنه باولئك الذين استخدموا الانترنت
مره واحده فقط في الاسبوع او اقل
[موسيقى]
طيب سالنا كبار السن في الشارع الاردني هل
استخدامك للانترنت والتواصل مع الاخرين
عبر المنصات المختلفه يساعدك ويجلب لك
الراحه والسعاده ويؤثر على صحتك ماذا
اجابه خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه بالتاكيد بجلب السعاده لانه في
احيانا كتير بتجينا اخبار بتكون يعني
جديده بالنسبه الي وبتفاجئ فيها وبالتالي
بتشرب لي السعاده
ممكن تتواصل مع كل الناس يعني باكبر سرعه
ممكن تتواصل مع مجموعه كبيره من الاشخاص
بنفس الوقت نعم
يعني لما تصحى الصبح سعيد او زعلان وتفتح
التواصل الاجتماعي بيسمح لك انه تتواصل مع
مع اشي بعيد يعني ما بتتوقع انه كنت تحكي
معه او تشوفه او كذا عرفت شو مثلا ممكن
عائلتك اولادك اهلك كذا اصحابك اصدقاء
زمان ما شفتهم
[موسيقى]
الى حد ما يعني بشكل نسوي بس بهالحد كبير
يعني بجيب السعاده بيقرب لك البعيد
وبتتواصل مع الناس المغتربين
المهاجرين مش دايما لانه اول اشي ما
بيخلوا الاهل والقرايب والاصدقاء انهم
يزوروا بعض ثانيا
هو في ميزه بس وحده انها كويسه انك بتعرف
ايش وضع الناس مين توفى مين صار عنده
مناسبه مين صار بس من خلالها
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا للحديث اكثر عن الموضوع معنا
الان في الاستوديو والاستشاريه النفسيه
نادر ياغي اهلا بك دكتور معنا صباح الخير
والالوان البهيجه
استخدام الانترنت لكبار السن يحميهم من
الخرف ويعني يزيد سعادتهم خلينا نحكي بشكل
تفصيلي اكثر كيف بتاثر الانترنت شو
العناصر الموجوده بالانترنت اللي ممكن
تحافظ علينا نفسيا خصوصا في مرحله كبار
السن ممكن يتعرضوا لبعض الاكتئاب او
الوعكات الصحيه اللي بتاثر على نفسيتهم
كيف ممكن الانترنت تساعدهم البدايه كانت
مع كبار السن في برامج قبل كليه هذه
المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي للمسميات
تبعتها كانت اسمه ام اس ام سنجر وحتى
الاشياء كانت لانه كتير في من كبار السن
في الوطن العربي الام او الاب موجود في
دوله وابنائه واولاد واولاده موجودين في
دوله اخرى كانت البدايه هنا كانت بدايه
التواصل انهم كانوا بيحبوا الانترنت صاروا
يتواصلوا مع الاب والام الكبار في العمر
عن طريق هذه المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اصبح الموضوع الكبار في السن انا بتكلم
الان عن تجربه شخصيه كانت بسيدتين وصلنا ل
28 منهم هي والدتي وبعض النساء الاخرين
كيف موضوع التواصل صار مهم جدا في حياتهم
فكره الخرف والكبار في السن وبصير ينسى
الذاكره اللي احنا بنسميها القصيره او
اللي هي مسمى الزهايمر والاشياء هذه
ابتديت معهم في قصه انه من عبر الانترنت
احنا نعمل حاجه اسمها حلول يشتغلوا على
حاجه اسمه صدوقه له العلاقه بالارقام
والكلمات المتقاطعه نعملها على الطبيعه
واللي عندي في بعض منهم ما يكملوا اكثر من
14 دقيقه يكونوا هم خلصوها فصار مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بالنسبه للكبار في السن
نوع من انواع تنشيط الذاكره ومش اني انا
بالعكس يصير في خمول بالنسبه للاطفال
المراهقين العكس النتيجه بتكون منااسه
اقوى للكبار في السن عن المراهقين
والاطفال بالعكس لان انا عندي تنشيط لهم
اقوى من الطفل لانه هو الطفل خلاص هو
بياخد المعلومه هاي على على صعيدين الصعيد
النفسي والصعيد الصحه النفسيه العقليه
اقصد كيف يمكن ذلك ان يساهم بانه
حفيدك او ابنك الصغير في السن ممكن يساعد
هذا الشخص الكبير في السن انه يتعلم
مفاتيح جديده للانترنت
والبرامج والتطبيقات الان حنروح على القصه
اللي هي التانيه اللي هم الاطفال
والمراهقين الصغار في العمر هم عندهم خبره
اكثر في التواصل عندهم خبره اكثر في
الايميل لانه للاسف كل اللي عندهم
ايميلاتي بيرجعوا بعد فتره بينسوا
الباسورد
دائما الاطفال هم اللي بيبداوا يعلموها
فالتواصل ما بين الكبار والصغار وهذه انا
بشوفها بمشاهد عندي في المنزل ما بين
الوالده والاولاد اختي هم اللي صاروا
يعلموها احفاد
احفادها لا انت بتعملي الباسورد كذا حتى
وصلنا في الاخر احنا قلنا عشان ما تلخبطوا
اعملوا الباسورد نفس الرقم تبع الموبايل
واللي انتم تعمل هذا شو ينعكس على الكبير
بالعكس بيتقبلوها بيتقبلوها من الصغار ما
في ناس في الاول يقول لك لا انا ممكن
الاطفاء الطفل الكبير يتحسس من الطفل لا
بالعكس بيكون سعيد انه ابن ابنه
يتواصل قبل
الى اي مدى ايضا هذا الموضوع
الشغل على الانترنت لكبار السن بحميهم من
العزله والشعور بالغربه بعلمهم لانه
العالم تغير كتير من وقت ما كانوا هن في
اوجهم لغايه الان وهم في سن كبير كله على
الكاميرات صارت الكبار في السن السيدات
بالذات او الرجال بيعطوا نصائح حتى
للسيدات الاخريات اللي لسه متزوجين اعمل
الاكل بطريقه هذه اعملي كذا كذا بالعكس
انا شايف مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي للكبار
في السن احسن خطوه من جميع المراحل الاخرى
مع احترام
كله قبلي
طيب شكرا جزيلا
الاستشاري النفسي نادر يجي احنا قاعد نغير
الباسوردات ها ولا وصلنا الى مرحله باسورد
واحد باسوورد الله يستر يعني ههه شكرا
جزيلا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات